-You started in stand-up.
You still do stand-up.
I know you were just in Vegas
doing stand-up.
-I was. I was with David Spade.
-David Spade, a very funny guy.
-He's hysterical.
Me and David were at the --
You know what, I got to tell
what you happened in Vegas.
This is funny. Years ago,
before I was doing "AGT,"
I hosted a game show
called "Deal or No Deal."
-Yeah.
-And "Deal or No Deal"...
[ Scattered cheers
and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I'm holding for applause.
Because you can fill in
more later. Right?
-Yeah, we'll just put...
-Oh, sit down. Sit down!
[ Laughter ]
That's crazy.
I wasn't expecting
this kind of response.
But -- so they have
"Deal or No Deal" slot machines
in the casino.
And we went there,
my wife was with me,
and we went with another couple,
Louie and Kathy.
And they were downstairs
in the casino, and before
the show, I stay in the room.
My wife calls me in the room
and said,
"Howie, you've got to see this.
Louie was playing
the 'Deal or No Deal' machine,
he hit the jackpot
and won $10,000."
-Fantastic.
-"You've got to see that."
I said, "Well, that's great!"
I put on my coat,
I ran out of my room, down
the hall, into the elevator.
Across the whole casino,
I see the lights going off on
the "Deal or No Deal" machine.
His wife is crying.
They're peeling off hundreds.
They're giving her $100,000.
I go and give them a hug,
and this is life-changing.
$10,000. And I notice
there's lights
and a crowd around me
and I look,
and people are taking pictures.
And then I realize they have
no idea that this is my friend.
People think that
if you hit the jackpot...
[ Laughter ]
...on the "Deal or No Deal"
machine, I show up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, thank you.
So I looked at them, and I went,
"Oh, somebody just hit in Reno!"
And I went and then --
[ Laughter ]
You can see in the distance
the whole crowd moving over
to the "Wheel of Fortune"
machine, awaiting Pat Sajak.
-Yeah, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-So this is very exciting.
This is the twelfth season
of "America's got talent."
So your sixth season.
-Eight.
-Oh, it's eight for you.
Oh, you were doing
the Canadian exchange.
I see what you were doing there.
-Yeah, I was shifting it back.
-Our years.
-And first year with glasses
though for you.
-You know, you've noticed?
-Yeah.
-You noticed.
You know what's weird?
I'm an old guy and apparently
my wife said,
"When's the last time
you went to the optometrist?"
I've never been
to an optometrist.
-Yeah.
-I went this year.
And I don't think my --
my vision is no different
than I've ever noticed it.
He said that I'm legally blind.
These are very strong.
And I put them on --
[ Laughter ]
Why does my inability to see
make you laugh?
[ Laughter ]
But now I have to wear glasses
and I'm wearing glasses
full-time.
Not for reading, full time.
I was blind.
I was legally blind.
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
And I have been judging
a talent show for eight years.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This...
This is the first season
I've seen it!
It is so good!
-Yeah. Congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
-It is so good.
And we're going live
this Tuesday
and I'm going to be
tweeting live.
Are you are you big on Twitter?
-Yeah.
-@HowieMandel.
I love to tweet live.
Follow me. Follow me.
-You're coming off a little
desperate right now.
-No, no!
[ Laughter ]
You're not --
you don't understand --
-The twitter thing was --
I was finished.
I'm looking at people there
and I'm saying,
at the end of the show,
I'm going to be in the lobby.
And I want all of you to follow
me someplace, not on Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
Just really, literally,
I want this --
-Yeah.
-Wouldn't it be great to
show back up in my hotel
with all of these people?
-Yeah.
Just wait until the rest
of the show is over.
Don't follow him now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't wait.
That's very exciting
that you're doing
the live shows.
That's great.
-It is very exciting.
At the Dolby Theatre live
Tuesdays and Wednesdays.
This year is more exciting
and better than any other year.
I mean, we got --
We have some superstars.
Last year my Golden buzzer
won Grace VanderWaal,
this 12-year-old.
-She was fantastic.
-A genius, songwriter,
performer who is going to be --
I promise you still.
You know, she's, like,
number-one selling in Japan now.
-Oh, that's great.
-She had the number-one
downloading iTunes last year,
a single,
and she's just growing,
and this year,
I have another Golden buzzer.
This young boy, Christian,
is -- isn't that weird
that a Jew pressed a buzzer
for a Christian?
-That's good. I feel like
the worlds are coming together.
-That's what I do.
-We need more of that.
-Thank you so much for
being here, Howie.
-Thank you for having me.
-Howie Mandel, everybody!
"America's Got Talent,"
Tuesdays and Wednesday nights
at 8:00 here on NBC.